Last week, the billionaire
businessman Richard Branson
hurled himself to the edge of space
on a ship he helped
privately fund and develop,
and came back smiling.
Now Jeff Bezos is doing the same.
Billionaires launching themselves
skyward on their own dime
has occasioned a bitter debate
about income inequality,
whether the government should
be taking more of their wealth
through taxation.
Here on earth, in the richest
country on the planet,
half our people live paycheck to paycheck,
complained Bernie Sanders,
But hey, the richest guys in the world
are off in outer space.
Yes. It's time to tax the billionaires.
The anger directed at Bezos
Branson, and SpaceX's Elon Musk
stands in striking contrast
to the high approval
long enjoyed by NASA,
even though the space agency
spent the better part of the last decade
unable to get humans off-planet at all,
while still soaking up
billions in taxpayer dollars.
Should billionaires play out
their space travel fantasies,
tweeted Congressman Ro Kahanna,
a member of the NASA Caucus,
or should we invest in
schooling, provide healthcare,
and create prosperity for everyone?
The irony is that NASA takes
our money without our consent
to finance a space program
that no ordinary citizen
can ever hope to access.
But when Branson, Musk, and
Bezos spend their wealth
with the explicit goal of
selling ever cheaper tickets
to all comers,
that's when congressmen get grumpy.
There's every reason to believe
the democratization of
space travel is upon us.
Bezos, Branson, and Musk
have already delivered on
that promise in other sectors,
unless the government
manages to screw things up.
Following the pattern
of commercial air travel
in the 20th century,
a novelty for billionaires today
may well be accessible
to the ordinary rich,
and then the middle class soon enough.
The billionaires also say
they're taking a long-term view.
One day, the capacity to get
off planet cheaply and at scale
could be humanity's salvation.
But what they want or envision
isn't what really matters.
Just as bubble wrap was
invented to be wallpaper
and Listerine was for cleaning floors,
consumers will decide
where the private space
industry ultimately leads.
Bezos, Branson, Musk,
and others have overtaken
a wildly expensive,
ineffective government program
and built a competitive industry,
driving down the cost
of getting a kilogram
into Low Earth Orbit by 44 fold already.
Which billionaire goes to
space first, how high he flies,
or how big his rocket is,
or how much he pays in income taxes,
none of that matters.
What matters is what the
rest of us are gonna do
with access to those same spacecraft
and bigger, better, weirder
ones in the years to come.
Woo, space!